[Music]
welcome back to CBS mornings here at 7
30 in the mass shooting in Texas is
renewing a lot of questions including a
big one what can be done to end this
cycle of gun violence in America in this
latest instance eight people killed with
an AR-15 style rifle including children
and we can all agree it happens far too
often so to talk about some of the
potential answers we are joined Now by
Republican senator Bill Cassidy of
Louisiana Senator thank you very much
for being here thank you for having me
we have so many important issues in this
country but the gun issue is so urgent
it seems like all we can talk about
sometimes and I know you always say as a
physician don't just do something think
so when something like this happens what
do you think well first we have to say
that when it's a tragedy I mean your
heart just oh my gosh it's a tragedy of
itself and then the children there that
just breaks your heart even more I I
would say though that we have the
response to the evaldi shooting the
safer communities act bipartisan bill
which is yet to be fully implemented if
you think about the three things that
usually result in a mass shooting
motivation domestic violence criminal
gang activity or someone who's mentally
ill the evolvedi response bill has
something to address each of those I
will say that it's a big Bill I'll also
say the Administration has been slowed
to implement portions of it let's get it
out let's push it and let's see what
effect that has well then just to
clarify it for people breaking out that
big Bill into individual points we were
looking at a Fox News poll earlier this
morning that shows 80 plus support or
almost 80 percent support for things
like criminal background checks moving
the age of gun purchases up to 21. even
almost 80 support for a 30-day waiting
period of those issues this is
Republicans this is Republicans with
support at that level would you support
any of those actions but let's look at
what we already have I would I would
support it if it makes a difference
perhaps
let me phrase this and the evali
response Bill we increase the time
period for the background check to occur
does it have to be 30 days no it has to
be long enough to be effective and for
those who are considered at higher risk
we gave a longer period of time for
authorities to be able to do a
background check and it's predicted that
if this had been the case you can look
at the shooting in Charlotte in South
Carolina I'm sorry the one where the man
walks into the African-American church
that would have given them time to
prevent that so it's not the length of
time it's the adequacy I think in that
bill we increase the adequacy I mean
there's there's definitely evidence
though that that criminal background
checks if Universal would make a
difference in the states where they have
them they have a lower homicide rate
we've had people under the age of 21 buy
guns legally do terrible things with
them so raising the age could help I
mean but can I respond to that last four
so again on the revolta response Bill a
lot of the people who have bought
weapons when they were younger
had a record when they were an
adolescent that would have been a red
flag they turn 18 those records are
sealed they go out and buy a weapon
because the the reason to not let them
buy is now sealed under the avaldi
response Bill we allow a judge to say
wait a second you can unseal those you
can look at those pull them out and see
whether or not this person should or
should not have a weapon so I would
argue that we address this situation
that you brought up but it has to be
completely implemented but in the
meantime guns are which is shocking to
many people guns are still the leading
cause of death for children more than
motor vehicle accidents cancer heart
disease
every time it blows me away every time I
hear it every time that there's an
incident someone always comes up but in
this case in this case in this case what
can be done right now what can be done
right now because it's no longer a
matter of if it can happen to you it
almost seems like a matter of when it
could happen to you so Gail I think if
I'm correct most of those deaths among
children are accidental yes we read
about the shooting in the mall but most
of them are accidental it is up to
apparent to make sure that a child does
not access to a weapon I've sponsored
legislation that would give a tax credit
that would allow parents to lock up
their gun you know give them a tax
credit to buy the safe so that they can
lock it up so the child cannot get there
why not go further and mandate that
people who own guns have lock boxes I
know gun owners often say well look I
need to get to that gun quickly that's
why I own the gun in the first place but
why not make it a law not just a an
encouraged action Tony what if you're
poor what if you're buying the weapon
because you're thinking your inner city
neighborhood somebody's going to break
in that's increasingly common that such
people are buying weapons and all of a
sudden you're poor but now you got to
buy something else I think you have to
step into people's lives and when you
step into their life it's a little bit
more complex than a wonderful show like
this where we say well what about the
solution what about that are there
behind the scenes conversations with
Republicans about listen this has gotten
out of control we really need to do some
at this point I don't even know what you
need to do right but are there behind
the scenes conversation because I always
know there's a public conversation and
there's a private conversation among
parties in both sides is there anything
going on behind the scenes again I'll go
I keep saying this but it's just so true
but nothing changes you've gotten you've
got to you've got to implement the
ability response Bill let me give you an
example of a conversation I had I'm a
superintendent of Education in Louisiana
calls me up and says we are not allowed
to use this money to harden schools
what and the revolting response Bill we
saw that some schools are very
vulnerable and we put dollars forward so
that there would be a place where
somebody could be screened before they
go in and perhaps cause harm yeah the
rules coming out of the administration
were that you can't use it to harden
schools I call it I call Secretary
Cardona okay I will correct that but
he's only issued that correction for
three schools three states yeah so so
we've got to push that money out and see
what happens Senator we understand that
there are complexities to this and I
want to maintain a certain level of
sensitivity as I ask this question
because we do have victims that are
dealing and still healing but one
bystander who was treating one of the
victims
said he found one victim without a face
and this points to the issue of the
types of firearms that people are
walking into these malls with walking
into our schools our churches and it
seems like these assault rifles rifles
are being used more and more
what are we doing about giving these
weapons of war to people
who shouldn't have them yeah so and
they've already response bill which
again has to be fully implemented I hear
you yes
um uh if you go back to the shootings
that I described they're either
gang-related domestic violence or they
are going to be someone who's mentally
ill okay now in each of those we attempt
to address it now Nate I don't know
anything about you man except that
you're a former wide receiver and you
got a tie that I never thought you could
wear on TV thank you man here's your
research works as a bandana that is a
compliment uh it's a great day
um so but if you had a weapon I would
have no problem with it uh what you did
is if somebody has to go to criminal
background and they obtain whatever
weapon it is AR-15 or not we um and they
they obtain it illegally we attempt to
go after the person who bought it for
that Criminal Who allowed that criminal
to obtain it illegally we have to
recognize that we can ban these weapons
but there's Millions already out there
and somebody who decides to obtain one
illegally probably can so we need to
stop that illegal transaction we can say
let's ban them they're already out there
by the millions so what do we do we have
to do something yeah yeah do you believe
Senator you're doing all you can do do
you believe that oh yeah and as I was
mentioned I had a conversation with
secretary gardona we have these dollars
out there to harden school this was
after Nashville and at the time they
weren't going to release them unless
there was a previous history of threat
at a school wait we're trying to be
ahead of a threat not react
and so I can I can look at what I'm
doing in terms of mental health in terms
of attempting to implement the Uvalde
response Bill and other things to say
that I am leaning into this issue yeah
we wanted to touch on the economy but uh
that that just means you have to come
back yeah we've got a lot we can get to
I'll let you borrow my ties no no let me
see the next one man let me see the next
one did you hear he said spice up your
outfit a little bit
I'm tired my friend Linda's in this is
The Loner all right listen to CBS
mornings we'll be right back oh man